Los padres pueden aprender mucho de eso.
Pero para mí, "Adaptarse todo el tiempo" significa algo más profundo, también.
Tenemos que romper esta camisa de fuerza paterna de
que las únicas ideas que podemos intentar en casa
son las que provienen de psiquiatras o de gurús de la autoayuda
o de expertos en familias.
La verdad es que sus ideas son obsoletas,
considerando que en todos estos otros mundos existen nuevas ideas
para hacer que los grupos trabajen eficazmente.
Tomemos solo unos ejemplos.
Tomemos el mejor momento de todos: la cena familiar.
Todo el mundo sabe que cenar en familia
con sus hijos es bueno para los niños.
Pero para muchos de nosotros, no funciona en nuestras vidas.
Conocí a un famoso chef en Nueva Orleans, que dijo:
"No hay problema, solo ajustaré la cena familiar.
No estoy en casa, ¿no puedo hacer de cenar para mi familia?
Hago un desayuno. Nos reunimos para comer algo antes de acostarnos.
Hacemos las comidas del domingo más importantes".
Y la verdad es que las investigaciones recientes lo respaldan.
Resulta que hay solo 10 minutos de tiempo productivo
en cualquier comida familiar.
El resto es, "no subas los codos a la mesa" y "pásame la salsa de tomate".
Se pueden tomar esos 10 minutos y llevarlos
a cualquier parte del día y tienen el mismo beneficio.
Cambien, entonces, la cena familiar. Eso es adaptabilidad.
Un psicólogo ambiental me dijo:
"Si estás sentado en una silla dura sobre una superficie rígida,
estarás más rígido.
Si estás sentado en una silla acolchada, estarás más abierto".
Me dijo: "Cuando estés disciplinando a tus hijos,
siéntate en una silla vertical con una superficie acolchada.
La conversación irá mejor".
Mi esposa y yo realmente cambiamos de silla para conversaciones difíciles
porque me sentaba en posición de poder.
Muévete de donde te sientas. Eso es adaptabilidad.
El punto es que hay todas estas ideas nuevas por ahí.
Tenemos que enlazarlas con los padres.
Así, pilar número uno: adaptarse todo el tiempo.
Sea flexible, de mente abierta, deje ganar a las mejores ideas.
Pilar número dos: faculte a sus hijos.
Nuestro instinto como padres es dar órdenes a nuestros niños.
Es más fácil, y francamente, por lo general tenemos la razón.
Hay una razón por la que algunos sistemas se orientan
hacia el modelo de cascada más que la familia.
Pero la lección más grande que aprendimos
es revertir ese modelo de cascada tanto como sea posible.
Enliste a los niños en su propia educación.
Ayer mismo, que íbamos a tener nuestra reunión familiar,
habíamos votado todos para hablar acerca de los berrinches.
Así que dijimos: "Bueno, dennos una recompensa y un castigo. ¿Bien?"
Así que una de mis hijas soltó, nos dan 5 minutos de berrinche a la semana.
y como que nos gustó.
Pero luego su hermana comenzó a trabajar el sistema.
Dijo, "Tengo un berriche de 5 minutos
o 10 berrinches de 30 segundos?"
Me encantó. Usa el tiempo como quieras.
"Ahora dennos un castigo. ¿Está bien?"
Si nos pasamos de 15 minutos de berrinche, ese es el límite.
Por cada minuto de más, tenemos que hacer una lagartija
Ya ven, está funcionando. Vean, este sistema no es laxo.
Se está dando un montón de autoridad parental.
Pero les estamos dando práctica para volverse independientes,
que por supuesto, es nuestra meta final.
Justo cuando estaba saliendo para venir esta noche,
una de mis hijas comenzó a gritar.
La otra dijo: "¡Berrinche! ¡Berrinche!"
y comenzó a contar, y a los 10 segundos había terminado.
Para mí eso es un milagro Agile certificado.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Y por cierto, la investigación respalda esto también.
Los niños que planean sus propias metas, establecen horarios semanales,
evalúan su propio trabajo, desarrollan su corteza frontal
y tienen más control sobre sus vidas.
El punto es que debemos dejar que nuestros hijos tengan éxito en sus propios términos,
y sí, en ocasiones, fallar en sus propios términos.
Hablaba con el banquero Warren Buffett,
y me estaba reprendiendo para no dejar que mis hijos
cometieran errores con su mesada.
Y dije, "Pero ¿qué pasa si la desperdician?"
Dijo, "Es mucho mejor desperdiciar
una mesada de 6 dólares que un salario anual de 60 000 dólares
o una herencia de 6 millones de dólares".
Así, la meta final es, facultar a sus hijos.
Pilar número tres: contar su historia.
La adaptabilidad está bien, pero también necesitamos cimientos.
Jim Collins, autor de "Empresas que sobresalen",
me dijo que las organizaciones humanas exitosas de cualquier tipo
tienen dos cosas en común:
conservan el núcleo, estimulan el progreso.
Y Agile es ideal para estimular el progreso,
pero permanecí escuchando una y otra vez, se necesita preservar el núcleo.
¿Cómo puedes hacerlo?
Collins nos entrenó para hacer algo
que hacen en los negocios, que es definir su misión
e identificar sus valores fundamentales.
Así que él nos guió por el proceso de creación de una misión familiar.
Hicimos el equivalente familiar de un retiro corporativo.
Tuvimos una fiesta de pijamas.
Hice palomitas de maíz. En realidad, quemé unas, así que hice dos.
Mi esposa compró un rotafolio.
Y tuvimos esa gran conversación, como, ¿qué es lo importante para nosotros?
¿Qué valores apreciamos más?
Y terminamos con 10 enunciados.
Somos viajeros, no turistas.
No nos gustan los dilemas. Queremos soluciones.
Otra vez, las investigaciones muestran que los padres deben pasar menos tiempo
preocupándose por lo que hacen mal
y más tiempo concentrándose en lo que hacen bien,
preocuparse menos por los malos momentos y construir los buenos momentos.
Esa declaración de misión familiar es una gran manera para identificar
qué es lo que haces bien.
Unas semanas después, recibimos una llamada de la escuela.
Una de nuestras hijas había tenido una pelea.
Y de repente estábamos preocupados, ¿acaso tenemos a una niña mala en nuestras manos?
Y no sabíamos realmente qué hacer,
así que la llamamos a mi oficina.
La declaración de la misión de la familia estaba en la pared,
y mi esposa dijo: "¿Nada de esto parece aplicarse?"
Y pasó la mirada por la lista y dijo:
"¿Unir a la gente?"
De repente teníamos una respuesta en la conversación.
Otra gran manera de contar tu historia
es decirle a tus hijos de dónde vinieron.
Investigadores en Emory le hicieron a los niños una simple
prueba llamada: "Qué sabes".
¿Sabes dónde nacieron tus abuelos?
¿Sabes a qué secundaria fueron tus padres?
¿Conoces a alguien en tu familia
que haya tenido una situación difícil, una enfermedad, y la haya superado?
Los niños que puntearon más alto en esta evaluación
tenían la autoestima más alta y una mayor sensación de que podían controlar sus vidas.
La prueba de "Qué sabes" fue el predictor más grande
de salud emocional y felicidad.
Como el autor del estudio me dijo,
los niños que tienen un sentido de... que son parte de una narrativa más grande,
tienen mayor confianza en sí mismos.
Así, mi pilar final es, cuente su historia.
Dedique tiempo a volver a contar la historia de los buenos momentos de la familia
y de cómo superaron los malos.
Si le dan esta feliz narrativa a sus hijos,
le darán las herramientas para hacerse más felices.
Yo era un adolescente cuando leí por primera vez "Ana Karenina"
y su famosa primera frase,
"Todas las familias felices son iguales.
Cada familia infeliz es infeliz a su manera".
Cuando lo leí por primera vez, pensé, "Esa frase es estúpida.
Obviamente todas las familias felices no son iguales".
Pero cuando comencé a trabajar en este proyecto,
empecé a cambiar de idea.
Un estudio reciente nos ha permitido, por primera vez,
identificar los fundamentos
que tienen las familias exitosas.
He mencionado aquí solo tres hoy:
Adaptarse todo el tiempo, tomar en cuenta a los niños, contar tu historia.
¿Es posible que pasaran tantos años para reconocer que Tolstoi tenía razón?
La respuesta, creo, es sí.
Cuando León Tolstoi tenía cinco años,
su hermano Nicolás
le dijo que había grabado el secreto de la felicidad universal
en un pequeño palo verde, que había escondido
en un barranco en la finca de la familia en Rusia.
Si alguna vez se encontraba el palo, toda la humanidad sería feliz.
Tolstoi se obsesionó con ese palo, pero nunca lo encontró.
De hecho, pidió ser enterrado en ese barranco donde pensó que estaba oculto.
Todavía yace allí hoy, cubierto por una capa de hierba verde.
Esa historia me atrapó por completo
la última lección que aprendí:
La felicidad no es algo que encontramos,
es algo que hacemos.
Casi todo el que ha estudiado las organizaciones bien dirigidas
ha llegado más o menos a la misma conclusión.
La grandeza no es un asunto de circunstancia.
Es una cuestión de elección.
No necesitan un gran plan. No necesitan una cascada.
Solo tienen que dar pasos pequeños,
acumular pequeñas victorias,
seguir buscando ese palo verde.
Al final, esta puede ser la lección más grande de todas.
¿Cuál es el secreto para una familia feliz? Intentar.
(Aplausos)